so let's reset trump's lawyer michael
cohen appears to be flipping as i told
you his lawyers are quitting on him he's
the target of multiple investigations
it's gotten so bad for michael cohen
that even his supposed unending love and
respect for donald trump isn't going to
keep him quiet and keep him from
flipping and cooperating with
investigators may be in multiple
investigations that's the the sort of
crux of what's going on so just as
quickly as michael collins future has
been torpedoed donald trump and his
associates have started to build this
effort to discredit Michael Cohen
sort of shocking from the guy Trump who
supposedly is endlessly loyal to the
people that work for him right and it
started a couple of months ago much more
subtly for example Donald Trump on
Twitter thing was back in April said
quote the New York Times and a
third-rate reporter named Maggie
Haberman who known as a crooked Hillary
flunky who I don't speak to and have
nothing to do with are going out of
their way to destroy Michael Cohen and
his relationship with me in the hope
that he will flip they use non existent
sources and a drunk drugged up loser who
hates Michael a fine person with a
wonderful family Michael is a
businessman for his own account lawyer
who I have always liked and respected
most does the key part most people will
flip if the government lets them out of
trouble even if as Trump says it means
lying or making up stories sorry I don't
see Michael doing that despite the
horrible witch hunt and the dishonest
media this is laying the groundwork that
when people do flip they don't tell the
truth this is layer one of preparing to
discredit and smear Michael Cohen as
untrustworthy in his potential future
cooperation with investigators layer one
let's look at layer two Alan Dershowitz
who has by the way jumped completely off
the deep end defending Donald Trump
endlessly he wrote an op-ed some weeks
ago where he also started to sort of
preemptively cast doubt into future
testimony from Michael Cohen writing in
the hill it is doubtful that Cohen would
cooperate even if he has anything on his
client referring to
but prosecutors often try to get lawyers
to sing against their clients to become
Canaries in order to save their own
feathers some flipped witnesses will
tell prosecutors anything they want to
hear in order to earn a
get-out-of-jail-free card they know that
the better their story the more leniency
they will earn so in addition to singing
they compose by making up incriminating
details listen when we talk about
torture
we know that torture is ineffective in
great part because the person being
tortured will say whatever they feel
they need to say to get the torture to
end right we've talked about that
endlessly Pat we know that they're
trying to say the same thing happens in
criminal investigations where when you
get a cooperating witness they will just
lie and make things up in order to get
themselves out of trouble and
potentially improperly incriminates
someone else this is a fantasy okay
number one investigators only even allow
a suspect to cooperate if they've
already determined that the suspect has
the knowledge and the information that
would be valuable to them in prosecuting
or indicted someone that's higher up in
the chain
they don't just offer anybody the
opportunity to get out of jail free so
as a rule as rme as Alan Dershowitz is
saying here not Giuliani
and then you're allowed to say whatever
you want and then they go in they file
bogus charges against somebody that is
not how it works and in addition to that
when you flip and cooperate they don't
just accept everything you say at face
value they take your testimony and then
they look for evidence and then they
look to corroborate it the idea that
there is any analogy between torture
doesn't work because the people will
just say anything which is true and
cooperating witnesses can't be trusted
because they just make stuff up and get
people falsely indicted
it's a fantasy that's just not how it
works yeah I imagine typically how it
works is you'll have a criminal who is
lying in line trying to get away with
what they've committed right and then
eventually they get caught and so they
have to come around and start telling
the truth they want you to deny that
logic
intuition that you have that that's how
the story goes yeah I just try to flip
it on its head but it doesn't work and
sources close to Trump are now making it
clear that Trump and his cronies are
ready willing and absolutely almost
eager to run a massive smear campaign
against Michael Cohen to preempt the
credibility of his eventual flipping
which at this point seems imminent as I
mentioned to you and the truth is that
the entire Trump is so loyal narrative
is only true as long as you're willing
to lie and cheat and steal and most
importantly protect Trump at all costs
Trump expects loyalty from everybody
else but he's only loyal to you as long
as you're useful in protecting him and
when you're not not protecting him
anymore
he throws you under the bus right away
and he's the exact type of person that
you deal with I was thinking you know in
high school maybe even in college
there's people that you don't really
like them but you continue to hang
around them and be nice to them because
they're popular or they give you access
to things or people that you like and
you want to be around them but most
people once they become adults do you
leave college you realize that the
toxicity of being around these people is
not worth it and you say you know what
I'm old enough that I don't need to be
around these people anymore and what you
have to understand is that the people
that are still surrounded that are
surrounding Donald Trump are the people
who never got out of the high-school
mindset of dealing with toxic people
because they're either popular or
wealthy or well-connected and that
actually gives us a really big insight
into the cult of personality around
Trump it's the people that in high
school were the sort of sycophants that
would just be around the popular people
to try to get the popularity shrapnel
they've never actually become adults and
they're still trying to be around
placating Donald Trump yeah you were
talking in the last story about how
Michael Cohen should maybe be on suicide
watch because he's gonna be in so much
trouble yeah you know if Trump the
person that he was such good friends
with is going to turn on him he doesn't
really have anyone left and he's not
going to be able to get that popularity
rubbed off on him so why would he stay
right and I think that that's the exact
thing that we're getting to the end here
for Michael Cohen send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show if I'm
wrong if you think that Cohen is fine
he's not in trouble let me
why because that's something that would
be truly shocking to me to hear